hallo mein name ist luca risso ich habe
schon lange ich habe euch bei twitter
geschrieben dass ihr mir reime zu senden
sollte und das habt ihr zahlreich getan
der erste reine ist dieser hier hat es
wahrscheinlich keine deutsche schule
oder ich spiele sonic auf der gamecube
und schau luca auf youtube ich bin
begeistert denn ehrlich also das was
hier raus haut das ist phänomenal ich
spiel sonic auf der gamecube und schau
luca auf youtube.de von brennenden haus
luca nicht erste fensters 40 hat sie
dann links ein poster von der action
oder was das findet ihr auch ein schöner
reihen der mir zu gesendet wurde sind
gut
du bist so cool und ich mache mich jetzt
nur auf dem weg zum beichtstuhl und
schwarzwald das was ich dich luca risso
cool ich mache jetzt auf dem weg zum
beispiel sich einerseits gereiht ich
kann nicht mal meine finger aneinander
kleben lassen einerseits hat sich das
gereimt und andererseits war das alles
ein richtiger dis und die bewerb die vom
gesicht her die dings darauf diese
schauspielerische leistung war einsame
spitze
also wirklich keine juni das war stark
dem droht luca ist brot luca ist tot
luke ist gut doch bitte auch mit dem
alten saft ist dass es kann doch nicht
wahr sein es ist halt wirklich so
gewesen die hälfte aller einsendungen
hat dieses beschissene worten
tomatensaft ich würde ich gerne meine
youtube karriere beenden wir machen
jetzt mal weiter mit dem nächsten freien
geistes luca roth dann ist sogar
blaulicht kann ich rein thoma wollte ich
mach doch keinen sinn dass aufzunehmen
da kommt diese die können nicht reinen
wie oft soll ich euch das dennoch sagen
tags kam wirklich not tomatensaft an
rosen sind wird falschen sie blau
mein kopf tut weh die hat mich lieber
bitte beim thema ich schaue mir jetzt
diese kurze szene nochmal an
ich möchte mal sehen
man halte ich theoretisch im remix raus
machen oder so ey alter wisst ihr das
könnte jetzt mal ernsthaft kann irgend
einer von euch irgendwie dumm was
zusammen schneiden und hat zeitweilig
kam überhaupt nicht schneiden und ich
habe auch keine zeit und ich bin ich
habe hunger tatsächlich dann versucht
doch mal ein remix zu machen mit diesem
auf den kopf schlagen oder mit
tomatensaft das würde ich mich auch das
muss ich sagen war ebenfalls sehr stark
es war einerseits der beiden fälle die
auf community
es hat sich nur die letzte silbe gerannt
das war schlecht doch kein daumen hoch
aber es war noch eine frage mit drin und
um darauf war darauf einzugehen weil das
richtiges dort jeder youtuber nennt
seine zuschauer irgendwie sei ungeheuer
familien es nudeln kranfahrer s kids
münchen
bin ich der einzige der nicht so dass
herr day am start wir müssen diese
videos nämlich immer morgens um 9 uhr
auf oder so bevor mein tag so ein
bisschen produktivität gewinnt und
deswegen sich mal scheiße braucht man so
was unbedingt für mich seid ihr alle
caracas wir lassen das einfach und ist
hier doch wer lieber bei dir bei seinem
bruder dem alpaka tier sollte
dazu geschrieben ich dachte jetzt alle
aber kalle ist hier wer lieber bei dir
einen höheren zweck in slate bei seinem
bruder dem wahlplakat ihr okay wenn ich
alle unbedingt zu mir kommen möchte
könnte man nicht schenken
ich hab eine ukulele eine wasserflasche
einen hund und neuerdings auch einen
play button als haustier eine fresse
bisschen kaputt gegangen das ist play
die daumen hoch davon habe ich auch ein
bild auf ein gramm und twitter
hochgeladen also folgt mir da ich
brauche follower ich habe gehört dass
man nach einer bestimmten anzahl
menschen mit seinen verein leiht gleich
einen leben oder so wir jetzt mal ganz
kurzes showdown alle leute die die
unterschied zwischen park und langweilig
kann nicht kennt selber nicht ich weiß
nur dass lamas anschein häufiger spucken
und alpakas teilweise in einigen ländern
als rasenmäher benutzt werden und ein
packers sind viel süßer da war mal pizza
jetzt ist sie weg lukas ging also wir
haben wieder hier echt also nöte 2.0
habe ich hier wirklich wieder ein weg
das ist doch kommen wir müssen uns diese
rat noch mal genauer anschauen da war
mal pizza
jetzt ist sie weg lukas ging so wir
haben also hier einen 3 vers da war
da haben wir fünf jetzt ist die weg da
haben wir ja und hier luca ding da haben
wir drei das hat es geht von vier auf
drei das ist ein es ist ein entertainer
außerdem haben wir genau an dieser
stelle ein wort was ich komplett feier
und dieses hier ist auch schuld an eis
das heißt ganz weit werte die ich voll
feuer allerdings haben wir auch zweifel
du dich überhaupt nicht feiern und zwar
einmal weg und stinkt feierlich und wenn
dir dann beispielsweise nämlich hier
zwei und drei wörter haben und dass
beides multiplizieren haben wir 4 und 4
+ die anzahl der versatz insgesamt +43
512 haben wir 16 und wenn man jetzt 16 -
es 13 rechnet bereits eine chance kommt
noch drei kommen wir zu einem reinen der
hoffentlich ein bisschen besser älter
sind sind rot falschen simpler ich bin
schlau
du bist in summe macht mich traurig da
immer noch scheiße reinkommt würde ich
sagen das war's ich hoffe heute hat
dieses video gefahren wenn es das getan
hat wie ich mich über eine bewertung
freuen und wenn ihr eventuell nochmal
sonnen ihr könnt mir reime zu senden
oder ihr könnt mir einmal videos zu
senden dingen wollt ich sehe gerade dass
sie noch einen reim reingekommen ist
vielleicht mundart der mich nochmals ein
bisschen auf luca du schaffst lichte abi
dem gefährt einen trabi